hi Danny how are you hey Dan what's
going on partner you okay
yeah where are you right now yeah I'm
actually in Fort Lauderdale okay Miami
burn up I heard you at dinner what my
buddy paid him texted me last night
yeah I I ran into this guy Tatum he's a
he's like a tornado when he rolled in so
uh yeah interesting where are you guys
in Dallas we're in New York
oh okay yeah I saw where you're going
into the pit Hall of Fame why did it
take this long for you to get into the
pit Hall of Fame you know that's what I
asked I was the funny part was they you
know I mean the schools been around
forever and I've never really had a Hall
of Fame so they just started it they're
doing it for all you know every sport
you know sort of putting four guys in
from every sport but I mean that's
exactly I mean that's the first thing
that hit me when I called me and asked I
thought we already did this like years
ago have they retired your jersey or you
got to wait for that too yeah yes no no
that's what I thought bigger you get
your jersey retired you're already in
the Hall of Fame you know but yeah I'm
going up there for the Pitt Penn State
game and they're doing that at halftime
and the football players of me Dorsett
um two green and Bill Fralick Wow so
they're the first first four guys
getting in yeah it'll be fun good
weekend now Tony was he was Dorsett and
then he became Dorsett or was it the
other way around when he was in college
was he big yeah Tony Dorsett no I think
no it's the way you said it I can't
remember Tony Dorsett Tony Dorsett it
sounds the same to me almost if it
wasn't pit where were you gonna go Wow
you know what I probably UCLA go that
way that's mean to say that now with the
UCLA fans probably going oh my god we
could have had Marino there who was
quarterbacking it UCLA it
time your may even remember God no no no
no chance to remember that one did you
visit UCLA I did I did UCLA Arizona
State Michigan State Clemson Wow yeah I
thought it was just a foregone
conclusion you were going to Pitt and
there was nobody else in the mix that
pretty much was yeah pretty much was I
just figured I'd take the free trips
I'm gonna guess you didn't get you at
UCLA there you look like you would have
been a UCLA quarterback I was noticing
this too
most passing yards week one in a game
NFL all-time norm Van Brocklin is number
one Brady's number two you're third on
the list 473 yards five touchdowns 1994
against the Patriots what do you
remember about writing that was the
first game coming off my Achilles
so I played for a whole year and I was
having issues with my you know because I
did that when in Cleveland where I tore
my Achilles and so that was the first
real game I played in and it was it was
a she got with black so I think he threw
four touchdowns in that game yeah what
do you remember about I remember most it
was my first it was my first game back
from the Achilles what is that feeling
like when you blew out your Achilles is
I remember seeing the highlight but what
is that yeah you know guys always say it
feels like oh my god yeah it feels like
you get like hit with a bat or something
like you yeah and then you turn around
like I like wow and then I turned around
I thought someone hit me there you know
there was nobody there so when there's
no one there that happens you know
you're in trouble so but yeah it feels
like you get you know yeah like he get
hit with something or yeah like he gets
shot
this is pop you can't hear it but you
can feel it you definitely can feel it
there's no doubt
I talked to Drew Brees about this
yesterday I said you know you guys are
all competitive I said do you feel like
you're better than Tom Brady or better
than Aaron Rogerson and me he was very
careful in what he was saying but he
said you know deep down you're come
editor and you feel like there are
things you do better than Tom Brady he
said there are things that Aaron Rodgers
does that I I wouldn't even think of
doing he's that he's that much ahead of
everybody else but when you played you
did you think you were better than John
Elway and Joe Montana well I mean let's
just put it this way you do if you're at
that level you feel you're the best no
matter what right so I mean now there's
nothing but respect for those guys and
they're amazing and they're friends and
all that stuff but if you ask them the
same question they would tell you the
same thing you know if you're gonna play
at that level you got to feel like
you're the best player on the field yeah
that's what I I think deep down breezes
as confident as he is and competitive I
mean he's being humble but I think he
feels like he's every bit the
quarterback that Brady is maybe not
Aaron rah I mean Aaron Rodgers is sort
of the Unicorn
it just yeah he does he does freak stuff
yeah I mean it's rolling the football
he's about as good as yeah as you know
ever was so he can he can plan I'll
throw it away moves it around yeah all
that stuff would you rather have the
best wide receivers or the best
offensive line if you're a quarterback I
think probably the best wide receivers
at the same time you know you're gonna
have because because if you're gonna get
the ball out and get a ball quick you
know you can I think you can get like
Aaron Rodgers I'm not saying anything
bad about the Green Bay offensive line
but if Aaron Rodgers the way he gets the
ball out the way throws it you could
probably get by with maybe not you know
five all pros up there you know I'm
saying you know yeah can you teach what
you did teach sweat thrown the yeah the
way I threw the ball yeah I think so
yeah I think there's a lot of you know
there's natural ability also if you have
to realize that at a young age and work
on your you know on your skill and you
can't I think you can teach it but you
know it's the combination of just truly
throwing the ball and no one what to do
with the ball and then having those
instincts
and I know that that natural skill to
understand how long you can hold it you
know it's got to be like a clock in your
head you know in some plays it's got to
be a quick clock in other plays you know
you can hold it longer than others and
that's all part of it so that all goes
in that's why it makes you know that's
why it's such a hard hard job if I come
back to the huddle and I say I'm open
how did you deal with sort of the the
politics there of everybody coming back
telling you they're open yeah I just get
open our next play out maybe I'll see
you see the film the next day and I'm
like did you see that dude standing
right next world we're talking to Dan
Marino what and Dan is let's see what's
the deal you're doing with Nutrisystem
you got so yeah yeah I said the
feel-good campaign you know I've been on
your show before we talked about that
you know and our boy Rick sees uh you
know he's been on it too lost a lot of
weight you know he's there he knows all
about it you know I think it's been ten
plus years now I've been doing work with
them and you know this time of year and
all the men around all football fans
that are men tend to gain weight so it's
all about feeling good I lost 22 pounds
you know yeah send it right to your door
and it works and you guys guys right
there fritzy and everybody knowing how
it does work so yeah and it makes it
feel good you feel good about yourself
you're healthier all right all that good
stuff you sure all the good stuff try
the new nutri pro shakes packed with
protein Neutrik carb bars and they curb
your cravings turbo boosters to rev your
metabolism lose up to 18 pounds eight
inches in your first month visit
Nutrisystem tom to get started today
have fun in Pittsburgh I'm glad that you
finally qualify to get into the Hall of
Fame there Dan hi buddy that's Dan
Marino all a favor for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]